well like all communities made a farlow
loss federal court funny horse is put up
it's remarkable that it's 15 months and
one federal lawsuit later these funny
ass but Muslims are going up America's
big Muslim pug come on America bring it
in yeah in this political climate we
kind of need to have funny messages
about Muslims when you're laughing it's
just really hard to hate just feel like
it is intensified and even for us as
individuals kind of carrying on this
work fighting bigotry I know that like
my personal the amount of hate mail I
get or desperate whatever is definitely
increased since 2012 well honey is no
but naughty little comedy can reach
people who would never listen to a
speech or read a sewage artic or watch a
documentary that's completely serious
and maybe learn something about Muslims
they didn't know before and make it a
little bit more familiar and a little
less scary and maybe actually become our
friend